i'm maxeen what from FX guide.com
forward looking at the tech of the
making of the king of zilla's the mighty
Godzilla Patil is a huge solitaire and
even noble figure almost oblivious to
man a metaphor for nucular horror and
he's one of cinema's greatest monsters
director Gareth Edwards was faced with
the task of modernizing the classic but
in a way that was much more respectful
to the past than perhaps the 1998 roland
emmerich film which depicted a more
iguana like creature initially
Godzilla's look was going to be very
much based on nature on real animals
that Edwards wanted to allow Godzilla to
act and express emotion so visual
effects studio MPC animated the new
Godzilla with enough human traits to
deliver an hour and still be one of
history's most impressive monsters but
it wouldn't be a Godzilla movie without
him taking some heat from the military
and fighting off some pretty serious
threats the climax of the film takes
place in San Francisco but Edwards
wanted to shoot as much real footage as
he possibly could for example the iconic
halo jump into the city while CG was
certainly added all the base photography
of the troops was real shot with a real
parachute team
similarly the arrival in the city of the
Muto's and Godzilla used as much real
footage as the director could shoot
which helps add realism to some very
unnatural creatures and give them scale
his newest Godzilla is the largest he's
ever been but unlike the current trend
in big effects films the director holds
back what this massive creature can do
until the end of the movie and even then
Godzilla's only really shot from
realistic camera angles often below
looking up the team word out that at
this size if he swung his tail would
actually reach supersonic speeds the
character is just that much bigger than
we've ever seen him before
don't forget to subscribe for more
behind the scenes action i mike seymour
for wide